how's it going guys Matt here from code
Tech tutorials today we're going to be
looking at the null object design
pattern and what it generally solves
we're going to be showing this in C plus
plus so uh yeah strap in we're just
gonna dive right into it as I adjust my
editor on the fly all right so I already
made an all object folder in our design
patterns folder for this repo I made a
main.cbp in an object.h to write our
little class hierarchy in that we're
going to work with so I'm going to start
with the Wikipedia example of this in C
plus plus and explain that but we'll get
into a few more advanced things later I
O stream we're going to include next
we're going to use it okay so uh what if
you uh have a bunch of animals in your
program for example maybe you're making
a game or you're who knows what maybe
you're tracking animals in the in the
desert or in the rainforest or whatever
so it doesn't matter just need an
example right that seems to come up in
all these tutorials it doesn't matter
just need some kind of example all right
so we have animals
um but an animal can't be generic we'll
say so we'll say we have to instantiate
one because we'll get to that a little
more later a little theory about how you
want to work with your memory we'll come
up later about this as well so look
forward to that all right so a little
Destructor there just because it's going
to be pure virtual and let's just say we
need a function here and on the
Wikipedia they have make sound but I'm
going to say like get animal type or
something
I mean git sound is fine make sound make
sound is this just gonna operate on it
and make some sound except in this case
it's equal to zero so we're going to say
you have to override it and we also want
to do a const all right so make sounds
just like a single action kind of thing
it's a weird way to put it but it's also
if you're virtual what makes this an
interface class so we could stick with
our standard and put an i here like eye
animal sure let's do that
so
that kind of seemed weird on this word
for some reason whatever we're gonna
stick with it all right let's say we
want to make just a dog so we need to
inherit from our animal interface and
override
we make sounds because that is required
Visual Studio should help us let's see
if it will do a little right click quick
actions Implement pure virtuals doesn't
work but it kind of tried unable to
create a function anyway we just need
this right there
instead of equals zero
uh we're gonna Define we're also going
to put in the word override before we
Define it okay so what sound does a dog
make I think we can figure that out it
makes a wolf or a bark or a growl wolf
bark growl
it's gonna make all three in our case
we'll put a new line there all right
well so now we have a dog that we can
instantiate we can go over to our main
guard me actually work here instantiate
a dog
Pixar include
the dog
dog one and we can call its operation
make sound that should be all defined
use IO stream do its thing and we should
be able to work with that let's go ahead
and uh fix our C make the rest of the
way but null object folder here because
we already got it uh here then when we
generate we should see it pop up in our
list of runnable executables here we
have some kind of error I put folder in
here instead of object for some reason
there's the null object executable and
we should be able to get the dog bark
sound here there it is
move background okay so the thing with
the null object is well what if you have
for example some client I don't know I'm
just going to call it client
that takes an animal
um let's say honest
animal
and it wants a reference so it needs an
actual instantiation uh let's make it I
animal here and let's say it just calls
an operation on animal like animal
not make sound now there's two things
here this interface cannot be
instantiated so you'll never never be
able to instantiate that pass it in so
there's one thing that's interesting
here
and how do we know if it's a dog or what
okay well and what if what if there's
nothing to pass in what do we pass in
then do we just make a random one no
this is where null comes in because
there's another way of Designing you
know if you do it this way you have real
instantiations that you're accessing if
you do it this way let's say uh make a
client two that actually it can be
client we can do some override
and this one also takes the same thing
but this time it's a pointer and it
would go you know something like this
got a d-reference make sound so this one
can actually have null but if you pass
null into here it's going to attempt to
call a function that doesn't exist and
your program is going to crash right
here so you need to do a null check
essentially if you're going to do this
you need to say if animal
gotta do that null check so you can
design your program in a way where you
never have to do these null checks and
that's a really interesting thing you
know that gets into more I don't know
what the terminology is for it but if
that's the way you want to go you can do
that to avoid have to do null checks you
just know that your program works
consistently it's actually pretty valid
thing to do
if you want to avoid pointers so you
would only accept references which only
are real instantiation so what if
something's not instantiated and not
instantiated and you need to pass it a
dummy model that's when you pass it a
null one so you need to make a null
animal basically or a null for whatever
it is so we're going to make a null
animal here and here it's from
animal and this one essentially just
does nothing we want to override a make
sound and we want to do absolutely
nothing
default behaviors
so now when we go through our program
logic and we decide we want to call some
function
on animal if we don't have a proper one
then we can make a null one
all right now that's kind of the
standard right there so down here you
would go client
we need to pass it something right so
let's make something to pass it we could
make a dog
and we could just uh pass it here just
like so that easy and that'll work
that'll call in right let's give it a
check
client a keyword
we're gonna rename this function control
animal be sure clients some kind of
reserved word or something I don't know
what's going on oh I probably just
forgot a semicolon or something yeah I
did right here and you declare your
classes and structs yeah you need that
semicolon all right
see if it works now and there we go it
does as expected calls the make sound on
the dog but what if you're going about
the logic of your class and you have a
control animal and it tries to take over
or call but there's nothing to call
that's when you want to have a null one
at the ready so here's another thing
about the null object you should
probably make it a proxy of some sort
and you should have one statically
initialized at all times that way you
don't have to always make new ones and
reinitialize you can just pass the same
null animal or null object around
so
if you just have in your main that's
fine we just go null animal I don't know
call it null animal and it does nothing
so if we go to this control animal
function and save for some reason we
have nothing to pass it where you would
normally pass it null maybe you just
pass it this instead and you kind of
make that as a default and you can see
that that does nothing
because it calls the make sound so in
this way we don't ever have to mess with
pointers and checking for null we just
stick with this system
and that's one of the main points let me
see if I can cover any further points on
this I think there's a few more things I
wanted to mention but I gotta look okay
well I guess another big takeaway here
just want to try to make this use case
clear is um just having one of these
null animals because for instance in
your Loop of whatever your program does
maybe you go into a bunch of different
levels and maybe you uh you know switch
scenes load things unload things go in
the different uh
Stacks we'll say are stack frames or
stacks of loaded data and you don't want
to be re-instantiating no animal all the
time or you're no object in general for
whatever your entity thing is you just
want to leave this one globally sit
there only instantiated once ready to be
referenced anytime
something is uh default but uh you know
it's a it's also nice because you know
if you're making database calls and
connections you can have the null one be
a placeholder that you know doesn't try
to open connections and all that stuff
and only when it's fully set up like for
example if you're building customers
instead of animals for example
you could have it so that the customer
has to have certain info filled out
before your function to make the next
call for whatever it is you need it goes
forward
and if they don't have all that you
could you know you could have it the
null defaults or whatever and those
might reject or not do what they're
supposed to do so that's all a lot to
say that you basically just don't want
to instantiate this a whole lot of times
by somehow making it globally
referenceable uh within its proper
context not necessarily Global but you
know scoped within its General context
like it might be within your empty
system you might just have one that
instantiates or something like that
and then whatever takes over your empty
system it still doesn't uh destroy the
null one every every time
or something along those lines and then
you know to talk a little more on that
you know if you're trying to get an
entity and it doesn't exist you could
instead pass on the reference to the
null one and say okay you tried to get
entity seven for example if maybe they
have IDs or something I'm not going to
code that up but you can imagine you
have an entity system and you try to get
it by ID it doesn't exist you could pass
in the null object there and uh have it
say whatever you want to say or do by
that overload uh not overload but
instantiation and then overridden
functions
so uh let me know what you guys think
let me know what you can come up with
with this pattern where you use it and
all that
and uh I guess I'll see in the next
episode peace out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign